hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to in the
mid-80s many kids were watching the
butches and yet somehow gayest cartoon
that ever hit the airwaves he-man I can
tell you what the story is about but why
not let him Anne tell you himself I
bring to the Eternia defender of the
secrets of Castle Grayskull a prince
really I never would have guessed
fabulous secret powers were revealed to
me the day I held aloft my magic sword
and said
oh I guess he was just going through bed
holding aloft his magic sword and saying
by the power of Grayskull phase but
luckily they happen to contain super
powers
except for Lou Shimer who apparently
always gets top billing so you get the
idea he man took place in another
dimension where he defended the Castle
Grayskull from the evil Skeletor it
wasn't a great show but we enjoyed
watching it and years later people still
love to talk about the gay overtones
this show gave us now many of you might
be saying no he-man isn't gay how dare
you say something like that well anyone
who's still in question about this
should take a look at the 1987 Motion
Picture epic masters of the universe a
film that teaches us it's okay to be gay
but not a god-awful piece of retro crap
so let's just jump in and take a look at
the first problem with this movie the
title why the hell is it just called
Masters of the Universe and not he-man
Masters of the Universe
I mean half of us didn't even know this
was a female movie because we never
cared what came after the he-man title I
mean all we ever heard was he-man
something something something something
so what didn't they leave it in I don't
know believe me that's the least of this
movie's problems oh my god so the story
begins at Castle Grayskull which
apparently is located in the Grand
Canyon the evil Skeletor has taken over
the castle but is angry because he looks
like how john mccain will look in a
couple of years the only one who can
stop Skeletor is the always shirtless
he-man who's played by Dolph Lundgren
you know the Russian guy from Rocky 4
trust me I'd rather have you break me
even sit for this ass fest this guy is
so foreign that I think even he forgets
what accent he's supposed to have no why
are you so important to Skeletor I've
been looking for you that's how Skeletor
his troops go into the city and
surprised it it sounds juror Russian
needs so he-man is accompanied by his
team led by men of arms who's pretty
damn old compared to the cartoon but not
as old as John McCain in just a few
years okay okay
that's last John McCain joke I'll make
intentionally he's also joined by Teela
man of arms daughter one-minute arms hey
that's not funny and will door who I
guess is supposed to be like Orko but
again why didn't they just make it like
the show and call him Orko sure he looks
like the gay love child of Yoda from
Star Wars and gizmo from gremlins but
we're not that picky because still call
Orko and we buy it
and speaking of gay just look at this
first action see
and tell me there's no homoerotic themes
going on here
but you would buy
it's like Star Wars only gayer don't you
just sad that guy in the crotch actually
there's a lot of shots to the crotch in
this movie talk about great balls of
fire
but again no gay overtones so it turns
out Skeletor is after will door because
he's invented a cosmic key that can take
you to any dimension you want
Skeletor wants this device a weekend you
guessed it take over the world of course
people of Eternia the war is to me shall
we destroy it sounds like John McCain's
inaugural speech to me okay okay I don't
even dislike the guy it just these jokes
are too easy I'll try to do better it
turns out Skeletor has also captured and
enchanted sorceress known as well
the sorceress he may tries to negotiate
for her freedom let her go
I don't think so negotiation is over
he-man tried to save the sorceress but
appears to be outnumbered so will door
opens up the key and sends them to
another dimension it's like back to the
future always Gator so he-man and his
team used the cosmic key to end up in
which parallel dimension ours of course
right dab in the middle of New Jersey so
let me get this straight
he-man the master of the universe is
going to use all his intergalactic
weaponry and medieval style fighting
moves in the suburbs of New Jersey this
is gonna suck isn't it
shit alright so he man is stuck in New
Jersey as they're looking for the
planets inhabitants alien life-form dick
let me blast wait
intelligent lighting in this movie I
doubt that oh look it's the best actor
in the movie mmm at least that line
didn't sell me Hearst
okay so what's the epic hero he-man and
his mighty crews first order of duty to
steal buckets of chicken from a
second-rate drive-thru restaurant of
course good food never think while
you're hungry I'm the writer of my
Kentucky Fried Chicken one of the people
who works at that fast-food restaurant
is Julie played strangely enough by
Courtney Cox
if you break up with Kevin Corrigan you
will regret it for the rest of your life
Kevin's changed I've changed hey you
still love him and being hue still likes
you when did this turn to Dawson's Creek
she's bummed because apparently her
folks died of some sort of plane
accident a year ago isn't this just what
you think of when you think of a he-man
movie your mom and dad wouldn't want to
go around the rest her life blaming
yourself
what No
I'm the master of the depressing plot
exposition ease meanwhile skillet or
tracks down their position and sends out
its evil team to find them which by the
way is it me or did this guy really like
dramatic turns seriously I wish I had
dramatic music every time I turn my head
I mean whoa so Julie and her boyfriend
find the cosmic key of skeletor's troops
close in on them look at these guys they
look like the Thundercats on the way to
the Rocky Horror Picture Show yeah
that's what I thought too Julie and her
boyfriend are separated as Julie comes
under attack by skillet or Muppet demons
he-man senses babes and decides he wants
to go after her once again we get an
erotic dance number which I suppose is
supposed to be an action sequence I'm
sorry but why does he man carry a sword
if everyone else carries a laser I mean
what is the purpose I don't know I don't
know after he mem rescues Julie he
decides to tell her exactly what he's
looking for
have you seen it it's this large it has
lights on it but again no gay overtones
meanwhile Julie's boyfriend meets up
with a cop played by the principal from
Back to the Future his job is to bitch
and moan as often as possible you can't
order me around what is this a circus
act
I got vandalism I got arsonist uh what's
going on out there we got stopped
blowing up in my face your choice really
choice this guy is so annoying he makes
Chris Tucker look like James Earl Jones
most of the time he's not even solving
any crimes he's just making fun of
Julie's boyfriend and messing around
with that cosmic key is it really wise
to mess around with the dimensional
manipulator I mean you never know what
kind of damage you could be causing
I don't think this is any synthesizer
looking for the key he-man and his
heroic crew decided to go travelling
around the city in a pink Cadillac
all right these are no longer gay
overtones this is an orchestra of
gayness and the shoppers of the film of
inoperable minerals
meanwhile Skeletor himself arrives on
earth bringing all his evil armies women
how does nobody in the city know this is
going on I mean are there really people
looking out their windows right now
saying boy that neighborhood watch is
really cracking down I mean while
Julie's boyfriend and mr.clean continued
to argue and bicker as no doubt bigger
and better action seems to be taking
place right now watching these two is
like watching an episode of Mad About
You only gator shut up
actually I think I realized why the
title of this movie wasn't called he-man
because he man's never in it most of the
time it's just focusing on his team
Courtney contra be a couple here I don't
worry everyone eventually meets up at a
record store where I swear to God the
weirdest combination of lines and images
come together I mean just try watching
this whole scene with a straight face
freeze Oliver let's start with you
blondie hey willow
how long to calculate the coordinates
intake so you'd rather stay here and
face evil and commandoes that's fine
with me but believe me sir you wouldn't
all right
someone has one batshit-crazy it's
either me or the moviemakers either way
I am very concerned feel like I'm the
twilight zone of comfort
suddenly skeletor's army appears and
they had to have an epic battle in a
record store a record store I can't
believe I'm saying this
no since its 2d way meanwhile one of
skeletor's henchmen poses as Julie's
mother who just so happened to come back
from the dead and needs that cosmic key
inside yeah this doesn't sound like a
setup at all thank you
I totally didn't see that coming
I seek not I'm sorry but listen this
trick used once in space balls that's
pretty bad what a film is so desperate
for ideas that starts ripping off Mel
Brooks sci-fi comedies so Skeletor gets
the key and demands he-man to be his
slave or else he'll kill his teammates
he-man agrees as his friends are left
behind with the other half of the key
Julie's boyfriend wonders why they can't
just use their key to find Skeletor
but Harry Knowles tells them that he
can't remember the exact notes that
could transport them back yeah
apparently the key operates on notes
instead of numbers or letters so of
course being the eighties it's
synthesized music to the rescue as they
rock their way to the exact coordinates
Ricky Lane the mr. time travelers I'll
be on your boy Joe back in Eternia
skillet or somehow got he-man into even
less clothes and tortures him with some
kind of holographics wiggler whip or
something look at this he's actually
leaning his butt into the whip like he's
actually enjoying it oh and I guess he
man sword is the only thing that can
give Skeletor supreme power the universe
or some shit like that so he points it
into his Nintendo chair it absorbs all
the powers of the cosmos while making
the longest goddamn speech in the
frickin world
yes I feel the universe within me I am a
part of the cosmos with energy Global's
through Ruben
and what consequence I know this planet
these people they are nothing to me
the universe is power few unstoppable ah
and I I am a koala
real before your pass
you live
yeah this speech is so long-winded and
pointless it's like being in a John
McCain rally
I want it swept so after his speech is
over Skeletor uses his demonic powers to
become a gay metallic Chiquita banana
Nader what but before he can destroy our
hero he man's friends come in to save
the day Wow the ruler of the universe
has really lousy aim so he-man breaks
free and starts using his manly strength
to defeat the soldiers he does this by
pushing over statues that are so strong
they actually bounce when they hit the
ground I guess they've been in the Sun
too long so he man gets his sword back
in battles the evil Skeletor metallic
banana thing it's kind of like Conan
only well you know this battle takes
forever
my he-man finally defeats old skull and
crossbones it's over oh good
I thought this movie is never gonna add
for you okay so he made the Pete
Skeletor again and then throw them into
a gigantic endless pit is it me or is
this the slowest fall in the history of
slowest Falls I think the movie could
actually start ramping up and he'd still
be falling you can you can't arms don't
don't say goodbye
there's an old attorney singing live the
turn for every destinations but a
doorway to another you look at me
I will activate the wave over are you
sure you don't want to go back so he man
saves the day the sorceress is rescued a
Julie gets sent back home oh wait
there's an added bonus they sent her
back a year before her parents died and
before nightgowns look less like the
clothing from Little House on the
Prairie so now she can tell her parents
not to go on that plane that would
ultimately lead them to their doom so
just to reiterate kids if your parents
die by some sort of horrific
circumstance all you have to do is look
for a parallel dimension that has big
hunky beef man who can take you back in
time and change the whole thing that way
you never have to come to grips with
death or the harshness of reality what
alone is that what you want to teach
your kids that family or loved ones die
there's always a chance you can bring
them back from the dead that's like
saying he-man is straight in that it's
not true to lie because he is so gay I
mean people trying to defend that he's
not gay you're just wrong well soon the
only thing care than him is this movie
it's stupid boring and a flaming waste
of time and that's not to say I have
anything against homosexuality it's just
there's got to be something out there
some kind of alternative hero that's gay
but at least gives us something
appealing to look at
you know what I'll take that over this
shit any day I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to